les spécialistes de la lumière trouvé
qu'il fallait modifier pas mal de choses
dans le visage se modifier
les gens ont toujours quelque chose à
dire sur ton visage
sur ton physique et tout ça est
et il y avait beaucoup de caméraman qui
me disait toujours qu'il menait était
trop long pour être bien photographier
pour devenir une star dans le monde mais
moi j'ai toujours j'étais toujours très
contente de mon visage de comment
comment je te fais et vous aviez dit je
connaissais déjà car au point qu'il
défend lui avait dit je ne changerais
rien arranger dit écoutez je suis très
content de mon visage les laits pas
question de charger ce que j'ai sur mon
visage et si j'arrive comme ça c'est
bien si j'arrive pas non plus je fais
une autre carrière et c'est fini